davos altitude 1560 mètres
niché au coeur des alpes suisses tous
les ans fin janvier la station de ski
devient la forteresse des puissants le
forum économique mondial une tradition
depuis 1971
pendant un temps on y faisait la
géopolitique du monde
yasser arafat est donc arrivée à damas
il est très doux joue à négocier en vue
du retrait des forces israéliennes des
territoires occupés
mais davos souffre aujourd'hui de son
image de réunions d edith et françois
legault risque de s'y sentir seuls
emmanuel macron ne l'accompagnera pas
trop occupé avec les gilet jaune
ce sera aussi sans donald trump empêtré
dans la paralysie du gouvernement
sans theresa may qui cherchent à régler
le breakbeat et sans justin trudeau
le thème cette année c'est la
mondialisation 4.0 la quatrième
révolution industrielle
notre quotidien la politique l'économie
la société entière sont influencés par
l'évolution technologique qu'à la pente
et des gadgets
il y en a partout à davos mais la
tension est ailleurs
[Musique]
la projection du film notre planète du
scientifique britannique david
attenborough semble avoir médusé
l'assistance
même le nouveau président brésilien
considéré comme climato-sceptiques a
voulu montrer un visage plus vers
d'autres visages connus profite de la
tribune ici pour un meilleur accès à
l'eau potable par exemple reste que pour
tous ces allers-retours à davos cette
semaine on attend quelques 1500 vols en
jet privé si mathieu prost radio canada
montréal